the idea of the whole
child pays respect to the fact that
there are many aspects of human
potential that grades can't measure
besides curiosity and intelligence
children may want to develop creativity
passion resilience intuition
confidence generosity mindfulness
humor and many many other important
traits
[Music]
edith ackerman's theory of the whole
child development
identifies four natural urges that drive
our growth
throughout childhood into adult life
being me
us the world and human creations
each of these four urges can be divided
into two subcategories
to understand them better let's look at
the theory from the perspective of a
young girl
[Music]
being me is about learning to use my
body and exploring my mind
the ability to control my body allows me
to discover the world
and as a result i can get to know where
i'm at and who i
am by using my body
i put my five senses to work this is how
i learn to walk
speak listen and develop healthy habits
soon i might impress older folks with my
clear speech good posture and other
physical capabilities
knowing myself helps me to develop a
voice in my home
and find my place in this world it
allows me to learn what i like
what i don't like and what potential is
still inside of me
by knowing who i am i can understand my
own subjectivity and form an identity i
am proud of
us is about how i relate to friends
family and strangers and my
understanding of their thoughts
feelings and behaviors
let me begin with relating to others as
a child
i seek the love attention and respect
from my parents
but i also have a fundamental natural
urge to have social interactions with
others
that means i need to learn to share and
care so i can belong
one day i want to become a respected
member of a group while keeping my own
identity
understanding others is another thing i
want to learn about my friends and their
emotions
intentions ways of thinking and
behaviors interest me
i want to learn to move away from my own
limited point of view
and integrate other people's perspective
to develop a more complex understanding
of morality and social problems
making sense of the world means figuring
out how things work
that's why we play through exploration i
quench my thirst for seeking logic and
discover this universe
adults call it exploring and
investigating we call it play that's how
we learn
sometimes it gets messy but by playing i
realize that some things change while
others don't
in other words i learn how things work
later i can become a real scientist who
plays with big ideas and theories and
explains the
workings of this world to you
i am seeking logic all the time us
children don't just want to discover how
things work
we also look for consistency where there
is little
to make sense of this world we filter
interpret and reconstruct what we
experience into mental models
i think adults call them schema this
urge for order helps me to reorganize
what i learn
infer rules and apply fundamental laws
in real life
human creations is about me being able
to imagine alternatives in my head
if i can image something new i am able
to go
and actually create it
imaginating is one of human's greatest
achievements
without imagination all innovation would
happen by chance
that's why i need fantasy and a lot of
free time to play pretend
this way i will learn to think out of
the box
through creations i can express my
thoughts and bring my imagination to
life
and there are hundreds of ways to do so
i can create atmosphere with my voice
ideas with my head and pictures that i
paint with my hand
if i am given the space i can create
cozy rooms beneath the kitchen table
or one day when i'm older design an
entire house
edith ackerman was born in switzerland
in 1946
after graduating she became a protege of
jean piaget
at mit media lab where she spent most of
her career
she was exploring the interactions
between play learning
and design whole child development
also known as holistic education seeks
to engage
children in the whole of their being and
potential
it assumes that each child arrives at
this world with their own set of talents
and
interests that are to some degree
completely independent from the child's
upbringing
[Music]
some refer to this whole as the mind
body and soul
the swiss educator pestilozzi referred
to it
as the hand the heart and the head and
further still
many others try to sum up a child in
four eight skills
social emotional and so forth but does
any such division actually pay respect
to the whole
does it capture a sense of humor and
appreciation of the arts
or the ability to be mindful for this
reason
the work of ackerman offers a more
wholesome perspective
what are your thoughts please share them
in the comments below
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license that means our
videos are free and
anyone can download edit and play them
for personal use
and public schools governments and
non-profit organizations
can also use them for training online
courses or designing new curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute
just visit patreon.com sprouts even one
dollar can make a difference
you